يواجه العراق وسوريا كابوسا يتجدد كل فتره
وهو كابوس الجفاف والتصحر والتحولات
المناخيه التي طرات على مناسيب نهري دجله
والفرات في ذروه فصل الشتاء حيث لاحظ معظم
سكان المدن الواقعه على النهرين اغلب
المدن العراقيه تقع طبعا على ضفاف هذين
النهرين ومناطق شمال شرقي سوريا ان مناسيب
النهرين انخفضت بشكل كبير في الاونه
الاخيره احتمال جفاف نهر الفرات وتحول نهر
دجله الى مجرد ساقيه صغيره باتت قائمه
خصوصا ان بلاد الرافدين تعد الاكثر تاثرا
بالتغيير المناخي سد الموصل الذي يقع
بالقرب من منابع نهر دجله القادم من
الجاره التركيه قد انخفضت مناسيبه الى نحو
30% مقارنه بمثل هذه الايام من العام
الماضي وكذلك الامر بالنسبه لمناسيب نهر
الفرات المسؤولين في وزارات المواد
الموارد المائيه يؤكدون ان العراق خسر 70%
من حصصه المائيه بسبب السياسات التي
يمارسها كل من تركيا وايران والى حد ما
سوريا في شماليه شرقي سوريا الذي يعد
السله الغذائيه يلقي الجفاف بظلاله هذا
العام للسنه الثالثه على التوالي مع
انحصار المساحات الخضراء الصالحه للزراعه
جرائم انعدام سقوط الامطار الكافيه منذ
اكثر من شهر
[موسيقى]